[Music]
for many many people who disappeared or
were killed by the nazis there is
nothing
there is no grave there is absolutely no
inscription whatsoever
except for a line
birth date sometimes
and a name
[Music]
these documents it's a testimony it's a
witness to what happened
the arizona archives hold 30 million
documents is the largest worldwide
archive on the persecution by the nazis
and on the survivors after the war
we had the intention to publish large
collections online and we didn't have
the resources
so we were very privileged to find an
excellent partner with ancestry the
partnership essentially involves the
archives digitizing the millions of
paper documents that they have and
ancestry creating searchable indexes and
people everywhere can search the records
for free
[Music]
seven and a half years ago i found a
list from auschwitz with my mother's
signature on it
it was a list of 227 names that came
from the harolson archive in germany we
can say the front is auschwitz november
29th 1944 it's a list of women prisoners
this is my mother's name this is the
number that was on her arm this is her
signature and what's most compelling to
me are the signatures each different
each representing their personality what
i've been doing since then is going
through name by name trying to determine
what happened to these girls what's
their story where they come from did
they survive
i felt compelled to go to
to see if i could learn anything more
both about girls on the list as well as
family members
this was a girl 15 years old as i was
growing up my mother told me if i would
have an extra piece of bread i would
give it to margietka and if you had a
gift of bread that means you get to live
another day
it is more important than ever to show
what can happen if these values
about solidarity about equality or but
respects are not upheld
living memory is dying for those that
were involved in the holocaust we need
to capture that information so that even
when they are gone experiences that they
went through can be preserved and shared
for future generations
wait wait what what what is this that's
my grandfather as well it's
extraordinary to see his actual
signature and that he touched this card
it is a privilege for us to contribute
because of people like alan
who are researching their relatives but
also other victims of the nazis because
we contribute to the fact that they will
not be forgotten
let's see
uh this would be a picture of my mother
in
germany i have the ability to do this
sort of research at the time many people
don't
for those who can't go where the sources
are stored
the ability to look at it online is
extraordinary and it's
a
wonderful thing that ancestry is making
it available for free to anyone who
wants to see
the reason i'm doing this is not so much
to pass this to my children
but to their great great great great
grandchildren because one day when they
wake up and say who am i what am i going
through here and when they look back and
they see what happened with their great
great great grandmother and her
resilience i want them to take that
lesson
you